mais d'abord le désespoir des parents
d'élèves de villedomet dans ce petit
village du nord-est touranjo de 1300
âmes il ne ferait pas bon être écolier
depuis deux ans à chaque rentrée
scolaire une classe est fermée à la
rentrée 2023 les 101 élèves vont devoir
se répartir en quatre classes dont deux
à triple le niveau les explications de
Clémence dosc
pancartes devant l'école Émile bois les
parents d'élèves ne comprennent pas la
fermeture de classe prévue à la rentrée
prochaine la deuxième consécutive en
deux ans alors que les effectifs ne
bougent pas les élèves scolarisés de la
maternelle aux primaires devront être
répartis en quatre classes il y a une
classe plus ou moins par niveau il y a
des classes de deux niveaux mais ça
reste raisonnable pour un enseignant je
pense trois niveaux c'est c'est
ingérable pour avoir une bonne
connaissance pour être aux soins des
élèves auprès d'eux être attentif à ce
qu'ils demandent et à leur connaissance
depuis trois mois les parents d'élèves
de plusieurs communes se mobilisent
contre les annonces de fermeture les
syndicats ont eux aussi tapé du point à
l'occasion du Comité Social
d'administration départementale début
février les dossiers d'une centaine
d'écoles d'Indre-et-Loire ont été
étudiées et désormais se sont 40
fermetures de classe 19 ouverture et 15
suppressions de postes de prévu à la
rentrée prochaine les mers des écoles
concernées ont été reçues par académique
mais ville domine a pu obtenir gain de
cause c'est un triple niveau à cheval
entre maternelle et primaires qui devra
être mis en place en septembre la
rentrée prochaine où il est prévu d'un
triple niveau d'autant plus un triple
niveau grande section CP CE1 donc c'est
vrai que c'est le cycle 2 le enfin c'est
le cycle socle que avec les difficultés
rencontrées de plus en plus fréquentes
chez les élèves avec des troubles de
l'attention donc triple niveau beaucoup
d'enfants si ça va être compliqué les
contours de la carte scolaire 2023 ne
devrait pas beaucoup changer dernier
espoir celui d'une hausse des effectifs
suffisante pour entraîner un ajustement
en juin ou septembre prochain